Trascrizione: Niccolò Porcellato
Revisore: Alessandro Lai
Buonasera, allora oggi voglio parlarvi di due donne,
di due madri e del loro coraggio.
Ma prima di andare a parlare
della loro storia che in qualche modo
si è intrecciata con la mia negli ultimi mesi,
voglio fare una domanda a tutti voi:
chi crede che le petizioni online
non servano a nulla?
Sono sicuro che qualcuno c'è qua dentro,
non siate timidi, c'è anche chi ci lancia le petizioni
su change.org per chiedere
che non vengano più lanciate.
Una mano, dai qualche altro coraggioso?
Due, tre, quattro, cinque?
Ok, sono sicuro che siete di più.
L'attivismo online è il mio lavoro
e volevo parlarvi brevemente
di quello che facciamo.
Ad oggi ci sono circa
100 milioni di persone nel mondo
che abitualmente partecipano a petizioni online
spesso ricevendo una e-mail a settimana
e attivandosi quando lo ritengono più opportuno
e io anche se sono un addetto ai lavori
non ho la pretesa di sapere dove l'attivismo online,
che è una pratica abbastanza nuova,
possa portarci nei prossimi anni.
Ma la teoria che vorrei portarvi
è quella che il coraggio collettivo
di milioni di persone
che utilizzano gli strumenti del web per attivarsi
e per mobilitare altri milioni di persone
possa avere un impatto incredibile,
sia per la vita dei singoli
che per quella della collettività.
Ma io sono un attivista e non sono sempre stato un attivista online,
questo sono io il primo giorno di scuola
davanti alla casa mia di Pistoia.
Vi racconterò una storia che non ho mai raccontato,
ho detto o la racconterò al TED
o non lo racconterò mai più.
È una storia semplice, un giorno
con mia madre andando verso scuola
incontrammo un piccione senza una zampa
e quello mi è rimasto impresso
come il primo momento in cui ho sentito
un'empatia
verso un altro essere vivente,
e anche forse il momento in cui ho sentito
che potevo fare qualcosa,
non solo per il piccione ma magari
per tutti i piccioni senza una zampa;
e con i miei compagni di scuola iniziammo un piccolo gruppo
che aveva l'obiettivo di cercare gli animali e cercare di curarli.
Questo gioco non passò inosservato
e le maestre dopo poco ci vietarono
questo gioco e ci suggerirono
piuttosto di raccogliere un po' di soldi
per donarle a un'associazione animalista vera e propria,
un idea sicuramente che condivido, soprattutto per gli animali
che poverini andavamo a stanare.
Però quella cosa li, poi quando ci ho ripensato negli anni dopo,
mi è rimasta come una forme di ribellione,
quel divieto soprattutto, come una forma di ribellione
verso l'autorità e soprattutto il fatto
di non dover sempre delegare agli altri
quello che per me era importante.
Alcuni anni dopo incontro Greenpeace,
è stata veramente una cosa molto importante,
veramente anche una fortuna aver incontrato gli attivisti di Greenpeace
e con loro per diciassette anni ho avuto la fortuna di girare molti paesi
e di partecipare a campagne e ad azioni per la difesa dell'ambiente,
azioni come queste. Era l'inizio... la metà degli anni 2000 e quindi passare
tra una gru a cinquanta metri d'altezza
all'attivismo davanti a un computer
sembra una cosa abbastanza normale
e credo che questo lo hanno condiviso anche molti attivisti di quel periodo.
Spesso salivamo sulla gru e poi scendevamo per parlare
di quello che avevamo fatto.
Era più importante cercare di capire come potevamo
veramente portare il nostro messaggio
e vincere una campagna.
Poi da poco più di un anno ho avuto l'occasione di incontrare change.org
e di lanciarla in Italia, e ho pensato come dopo diciassette anni di esperienza
avrei potuto utilizzare questo bagaglio,
quello che avevo imparato
in questi anni,
per magari aiutare decine,
se non centinaia, o migliaia di persone
a lanciare la propria campagna.
Perché change.org è una piattaforma aperta,
dove le persone possono lanciare la propria campagna
su cui spesso o a volte non sono d'accordo
ma posso comunque aiutarle a vincere.
E qui veniamo alle persone
che utilizzano questa piattaforma.
Questa è Gloria Ramos.
Gloria Ramos è venuta in Italia
vent'anni fa ed ha cresciuto da sola
un ragazzo italiano, perché è nato in Italia,
Christian, che all'età di diciotto anni
è andato a chiedere di poter diventare italiano veramente,
perché per i figli di stranieri nati in Italia
si può richiedere la cittadinanza italiana.
Con grande sorpresa Gloria e Christian scoprono che Christian,
siccome ha la sindrome di down,
non può giurare sulla costituzione,
quindi non è in grado
di intendere e di volere
e quindi non può diventare italiano.
È ovviamente un ingiustizia però per Gloria è anche
molto difficile da superare questa ingiustizia,
perché la burocrazia,
lo stato ti dice una cosa
è molto difficile rispondere.
Allora Gloria cosa fa, non si arrende
scrive una lettera al Ministro dell'Interno, la pubblica su change.org
e in pochi giorni raccoglie 30 000 adesioni.
In quel momento Gloria non è più sola
e dev'essere ascoltata,
quindi i media iniziano a parlare di lei,
va in parlamento a consegnare le firme,
e dopo poche settimane
il ministro Cancellieri intercede e oggi,
grazie al coraggio di Gloria
di mettersi in prima persona
e anche al coraggio di 30 000 persone che l'hanno sostenuta,
oggi Christian è italiano.
(Applausi)
Anche questo ragazzo si chiama Christian,
ma Christian è nato a Napoli.
Da trentotto giorni si trova
in una carcere russa,
e questo per aver partecipato ad un'azione non violenta
di Greenpeace a difesa dell'artico,
a difesa dell'ambiente.
Christian è poco più giovane di me,
veramente avrei potuto essere io,
sono stato su quella nave varie volte,
e ovviamente quando queste cose succedono
tutti ci mobilitiamo, io e tutta Greenpeace
abbiamo fatto manifestazioni,
proteste in tutto il mondo,
questa è avvenuta solo pochi giorni fa
a Napoli.
Ma siamo nel 2013
e questi sono i genitori di Christian:
Raffaella, che è la madre,
pensa che può fare qualcosa lei
in prima persona,
e per questo scrive una lettera bellissima
al presidente Napolitano
che vi invito anche a leggere,
la pubblica su change.org,
e in pochissimi giorni
raccoglie 130 000 adesioni,
130 000 persone che firmano questa petizione.
Christian purtroppo è ancora in galera,
però adesso ci sono 130 000 persone
che sostengono la madre e continuano a chiedere la liberazione di Christian,
e proprio ieri i genitori di Christian
sono stati al Quirinale e hanno incontrato dei rappresentanti, non il presidente,
speriamo presto che possano incontrare anche il presidente,
ma sicuramente questo
ha sbloccato le cose
e speriamo che questo possa aiutare
per la liberazione di Christian.
Ora io stavo pensando che cos'è che accomuna Raffaella a Gloria?
Il fatto che hanno raccontato la propria storia,
e l'hanno raccontata senza filtri
come gli veniva, come si sentivano in quel momento di doverla raccontare.
Il web è uno strumento eccezionale.
È la prima volta nella storia
dove le persone
possono veramente raccontare
una propria storia
usando gli strumenti di viralità,
gli strumenti dei social media
farlo raggiungere a milioni di persone.
E queste persone possono creare dei movimenti
che possono creare un cambiamento reale.
Io credo che nel novecento ci sono stati grandi movimenti
che hanno cambiato la nostra vita,
ci hanno permesso di avere delle democrazie migliori, dei diritti migliori
e se guardate quei movimenti,
la maggior parte di questi
sono stati iniziati e sono cresciuti
grazie a delle persone coraggiose,
dei grandi personaggi
personaggi come Gandhi,
come Martin Luther King, come Mandela.
E forse oggi se guardiamo intorno a noi mancano un po' questi personaggi.
Non ci sono più
questi grandi personaggi di una volta.
Però ci sono milioni di persone che adesso
possono usare il loro piccolo coraggio
per fare un piccolo cambiamento,
ma che insieme può avere un risultato veramente efficace.
Quindi io so che qua dentro ho sentito tantissime storie,
so che molte persone tra il pubblico
hanno delle grandissime storie,
delle grandissime idee
e hanno il coraggio per portarle fuori.
Spesso siamo noi che sabotiamo le nostre idee
perché non abbiamo abbastanza coraggio per tirarle fuori.
Io spero che qualcuno dei coraggiosi
che hanno alzato la mano all'inizio
siano i prossimi a lanciare una petizione
e a cambiare le cose.
Grazie.
(Applausi)